don't need Botox all you need is a banana peel
rub this banana peel on your skin
so what happens when you use banana peel on your face everyday
results are crazy in the first few days it contains Luton
an antioxidant
that neutralizes free radicals from pollution and UV damage
and this reduces skin damage and acne
now after 1 week inflammation reduces
which lowers cortisol and this reduces your sugar cravings
meaning less wrinkles whilst the banana peels
natural fatty acids and wax lock in moisture which hydrates your skin
now after 2 weeks you have a stronger skin barrier
and bananas enzymes exfoliate dead skin cells
which improve your texture and fades dark spots
and this boost your confidence and self esteem
now finally after one month
it's potassium helps regulate blood flow to the skin
boosting nutrient delivery to your cells which gives you a glow
so if you want to lose fat and improve your skin then follow for more